what's your Instagram right now let me
look at it I'm just honey
wait can we put it on the screen I want
to I want to react oh my God
I just want to see the type of stuff you
post right
hold on hold on hold on guys I am on a
journey of like becoming more religious
so I am going to Rebrand my Instagram
[Laughter]
I like how you don't say I'm gonna get
closer with god listen
please
Instagram is absolutely Haram
no she's changed she's changed now she's
changed accountability
I haven't changed right now but I'm on
the journey actually
no I'm just honey I'm more modest and
more religious but it's a journey it's
not easy Society okay wait what is
oh
Jesus okay thank you put in the
Instagram
guys
I am
j-u-s-t-h-a-n-i and then your honor the
evidence I'd like to present to the
court is uh picture number five from the
top and picture number one
pretty pretty
I don't this is this is was this the
type of stuff you were you were posting
uh look at that picture in the middle
that's Haram right there oh why are you
showing your backside to the world yeah
that's the that's Nikki still
you know I think it is yeah Instagram
guys that's that's not crazy
look it's Haram as in as in like okay
you could see a bit of legs you can see
a bit of hair but however even with that
most people would have been like oh my
God this is not even nothing but we're
in the Western United Society
I'm just gonna do you see how your gut
reaction isn't to listen it's to defend
yourself yeah yeah
I do that
like oh maybe it is a bit haramic
wait wait you're still waiting turn off
for Mike
yeah but it's like it's like if that's
your initial response that's probably
contributed something because like if
you think your exes could have told you
something
yeah but see this is this is what women
do too so you're still now you're saying
well it's how I grew up and so now it's
like it's not on you it's on someone
else
I've done this stuff before too it's
okay but it's something that I can
change but as far as let's go back to my
Instagram goes I battled this with
myself as well so I'm like okay I do
um I used to have way more pictures no
archived and everything and I'm
literally like slowly finding a way to
you know become more more distressed I
think it's a perspective thing you know
and it's not a bad idea
I'm not saying that's not a bad thing
that's good yeah but I'm just saying
when we look back at situations if we're
always like pointing the finger we can't
grow we can't get better yeah listen
let's ask the chat Chad if you think her
Instagram is Haram Pusha one
push it two right there
I'm hung up for not wearing a headscarf
so let's start then
we're in a Christian Nation okay so like
well I guess you I guess you're Muslim
but yes I battle myself a lot more than
ever but you know what I think it is
though I generally think here that the
issue here isn't necessarily intentional
or malicious I think it's just a
perspective thing in this generation I
don't feel like a lot of women learn how
men are like or how they think or like
what their desires are so so it's like
the way it can translate across is that
oh wait I see that men like big boobs so
that was clearly what they want I see
but if females actually sit down with
men and say what would you want from a
wife now you know from your Instagram
um early one you can 100 argue it's not
that deep you know you can argue on one
side of the coin but on the flip side of
the coin you can also argue where the
action she's faced away from the screen
got a bottom to the screen yeah the
intention let's say that you don't it
doesn't matter what she's wearing let's
say the intention alone how could people
perceive it could we perceive it as
that's a woman that's got a husband and
that's a woman that you know is in a
relationship leave it as oh she's single
like dude I'm saying how long ago do you
break I think this is a perspective
thing
um three years ago I would have never
get back with him oh this was three
years ago yeah but he he would always
come back I thought you said oh he'd
always come back wait wait I thought you
said he was eight you were 18 he was 28.
but so how aren't you 26 yeah so then
you would have been 23 is this a
different X yeah so it's okay yeah okay
so I've been with him for like four
years
so so when you were you were 22 you got
with him for four years no 18 I got with
him no no the last X how long were you
with her Portugal X
this was the main serious relationship I
would consider in my life the rest was
like getting to know you okay okay
how old were you when you met him how
old were you when you met him when did
you break up 18 we had an on and off
relationship up until 22 23 I would say
Okay okay so 20 18 to 22. yeah that'd
answer your question no
wait so eight 18 to 20s you dated him
for four years on and off so on and off
that means the relationship was [__] but
the sex was good no no the one
why is on and off no we've never had sex
I I oh okay okay someone else asked the
question someone asked a question
actually I'm a blank right now four
years of this wow are you a virgin
yes
do we have a stop
what what I don't know okay no this is
best we shouldn't even have this
discussion no no no no no no no nothing
about me right now to be fair it's for
me yeah I'm just learning it because
this is a completely different Insight
because because you're coming with a
Muslim background yeah and you got these
types of insights behind you yeah this
sounds pretty different to me like for
example you've been saying like you're
26 right now you're a virgin we're in a
western Society I haven't heard that
since I was like 15 that's something a
virgin this so that's some reason why
like we're asking and it's like
this is the thing as well they're
surprised because you don't portray
yourself like a virgin which is which is
a which is a great you know based on
that you're boring are you a boy I'm not
I'm not saying it's like a well is she a
born again they don't believe you but
I'm saying there's a reason they think
you're counting I'll be stupid yeah I
think you're capping no okay thank you
I'm copying for my Instagram but no one
has virgin on there no but I'm saying no
yeah but usually like I've had virgin
girls come on the show where nobody
really nobody really like wait wait
nobody really like pushes back right but
it's not like it's just it's a good
thing right that's like a great thing I
think that's awesome it is good but it's
like it's like unfortunate because I'm
like No One Believes you because of the
Instagram
it's like it's it's like it loses but
yeah that's a great thing nobody has
that that's why I want to change my
Instagram too okay I'm gonna go home and
archive that picture okay
I'm just gonna give you the chance right
now honey do you remember the
conversation we had before the cameras
were on
what do you mean about conversation
about the situation you told me about I
don't remember we were just talking in
general no but do you remember about the
situation you told me about that I was
giving you advice on
it was a general situation I can't
remember exactly where the red fault
what does that have to do with this part
because you just told everyone here
something that from that situation I was
that what were you talking about because
I wasn't talking about me and myself in
that situation you you were I don't know
what you're talking about honestly I was
talking about situation with my friend
just in general but I don't know I just
met you do I know you
[Music]
I've not said anything about anything
yeah I'm just saying do you remember the
conversation that we had I remember some
of the conversations we had yeah most of
them yeah this is like a politician
isn't it yeah
how long ago was this conversation this
was about an hour ago so you you
remember all of it then don't you yeah
yeah okay you know you're saying I
remember something I remember the
conversation I remember I was talking
about a lot of things yeah okay but no
but we specifically were talking about a
situation that I was giving you advice
on we were talking about for about 45
minutes right I was talking about about
a certainly in my situation that was
your situation no it wasn't
[Laughter]
I apologize if that was the case but you
could come check the label on my suit
it's it costs more than your outfit
hey guys guys guys let me just see okay
before hey okay cool well let me say
this you know the reason why I thought
they couldn't speak a bit of tension
right now and a bit of disagreements
only because the early one when you were
speaking about the city
um girl situation or the holiday thing
that happened I remember at one point he
did also say oh and then that happened
and it's not me saying that you're a
liar or anything like that it's just
that within this limited time of knowing
you yeah if I if someone says a story
then misses out a story I can only go
off my imagination and it doesn't
necessarily mean that I'm tying you or
saying yo straight home straight this
did it it's not that but you have to
remember all of us not all of us but all
a lot of us are just meeting each other
for the first time and we're going off
of you see first impressions are the
most important because they're the ones
that stick the longest so obviously in
regards to the Instagram it's not even
like I've looked into Instagram and said
yo you're dressed mad it's not even that
it's just that when you say I'm a virgin
and then there's quite a few westernized
similarities like it just in common
like do you see how someone that's a
stranger could be like oh maybe I don't
I don't understand no if she's a virgin
not black yeah that's fine but that's
you lost opinion yeah yeah that's fine
everyone can have different opinions
yeah yeah you can't you can't you can't
insult my guest I apologize for him
because I thought he was coming for me
and to calling me a liar that's why okay
okay I'm not here to disrespect anyone
but I just felt a bit attacked so I was
defending myself he wasn't he wasn't
attacking you I just because when he
kept saying I felt but it's like you
keep having this like visceral reaction
you can stay because you apologized okay
if you want to you can say but but you
can't you can't you can't insult my
guests like that's it's not but you
would you would deflecting as well
because it seemed like there was some
opposing evidence to what you're saying
no it wasn't it was just everyone just
putting their little two cents in and um
it wasn't you guys don't know it was a
fact as well so it was just a bit like
I'm saying what I'm saying you know she
just respect what I'm saying whether you
believe it or not and just call it a day
that's it just but to some degree though
like it's it's like there's something I
accept that that's fair it's that to
some degree though it is a it's a public
podcast that wall just putting opinions
forward in it like it's normal like
someone can put an opinion for you and
if I think yo boom I don't really agree
with that or I don't I could be wrong
you know but it's it's for you to be
able to be like you know what yeah you
may not be agreeing with me but this is
a podcast on it but it's like but people
are just gonna have something to say
against what you got to say of course
that's that's why I'm on social media I
already know that people are gonna say
they stand out about me so it's okay
it's cool where's my best actor because
I need to hand it over real quick
please
I'm gonna ask him questions and I'll ask
you questions so so this conversation
this conversation
[Laughter]
so so this conversation you don't have
to tell me what she said but it's
basically contradicting what she's
saying now
[Music]
um
there are some things that she has said
on this podcast right that does not
align with things she that we discussed
but it's her life I will not disclose
anything that she said because we were
discussion I was helping through a
situation so I wouldn't disclose
anything because if she doesn't want it
to be public fine but that's why I was
asking her do you remember the
conversation because it doesn't some
things are not aligning you know this
happens
okay I've warned you I told you I told
you I'm going to ask you questions in a
second okay cool no I need you this is
I've warned you you gotta go
all right that's fine I'll just go
because this is just feeling a bit like
too much of an attack okay okay
um I didn't come here okay okay that's
fine just go that's why
Troy I'll come sit next to you
please
I need a hug now
uh I know that's what they're saying
they're like why'd you bring it up it's
like
uh we're gonna get it today no you don't
you know what's funny though
okay do you know what's funny though
this happens to me all the time on the
show this happens to me all the time
where like someone will say something
but I don't want to say anything yeah I
can yeah yeah I I saw it in real time no
no and it's like yeah so I I know what
you mean
no go ahead
ultimately
like like
talking some people have been
new oh mine no no that one like this
but yeah if you're coming on the podcast
you should know what you're saying look
listen like Everyone's entitled to their
privacy Etc that but I'm a bit like oh
boy if you've said something I don't
know like if you said something that I'm
like ah I was just that's why I said
look I'm just saying do you remember the
conversation does the truth trigger
people
or do lies trigger people like what
which one is it what's inside are we
talking about this one the British one
ah depends on the truth
well I mean it's a little bit
disingenuous if you're going to come on
to a show and say something that's I
mean
that you you're directly contradicting
something that you've revealed to
somebody else yeah just prior to that
show well particularly particularly if
it's something that you're trying to
cast yourself in a good light
yeah
I understand because I'm like nobody
expected her to be a virgin you know
what I mean like yeah that's it I didn't
say that's what it was just for the
record I didn't say that's what it was
that was she was white a virgin yeah
that's what she was saying that's what
she was saying yeah
now once you lay it out it's just you
just accept what comes with it and so I
was projecting and maybe Troy gentlemen
you guys could agree with me or not I
have been in on and off relationships
with girls and the only thing that was
keeping us both there was really good
sex like yeah
Mr kitten do you agree with me to the
dating coach or no you disagree like if
it's on and off it's like you're having
sex but it's not a commitment but that
was not it
well okay so then and I'm open to
understanding the truth so like what
we're on and off was why did I stay what
was the on and off about and was it the
sex mediocre or
um
bro you gotta get off the shelter get
the [__] out of here get out of here bro
you're off the show
sometimes
sorry Mr Pearl sorry sorry
Mr Davis it was all right it wasn't
great so what is the context of the off
and on like what happened
um
it was just like maybe I'd like go
through his phone and find something I
didn't like you know I was kind of I was
kind of looking for problems if I'm
being honest yeah and I really would
overreact about a lot of stuff what did
you find when you went through his phone
um I don't
um you know like messages that sort of
thing but two other girls
partially but I I think I kind of
overreacted on a lot of them like it
wasn't really that deep were you
overreacting because you wanted to find
a reason to overreact or was it just
because you were triggered emotionally
um
interesting yeah it's interesting
because I was thinking why is it so many
girls will go through guys photos and
it's insecurity right yeah I've had
girls I had a girlfriend like every
single girl that I've ever dated really
used to would go through my phone and
there was one girl I was dating and she
would like literally every time she came
round she'd go oh yeah I've seen
something on your phone you know it's
very it's very like it's addicting you
got to get your next fix and that's what
I that's what I realized I was like I
keep like like if I like I obviously
don't care because I keep we keep
getting back together and I keep looking
for problems yeah is she still here or
what is she like no I think she laughed
it's King was she taken out
okay
um what did she say bro tell us
your favorite listen I'm sorry listen
listen that I don't think she's a virgin
I think she knows people that are going
to see her on social media and she's
gonna get shamed for being a shitty
Muslim I I have never met someone such
with such a visceral reaction
like virgins don't know how to be that
toxic
that comes from trauma I've had virgin
like girls come on the show and yeah
they're very Meek they're like yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah they're very Meek
you know you can you can tell
um
let's see it's consistent for me like I
see too many times that she say
something then someone else will say
something like oh I just remember this
happened too okay
give us the tea give us the British team
this isn't anything crazy but she was
she was like telling me a story about
like a guy or whatever that she had
history with and then she was saying
about how like her sister he then I
think she called it off so then he went
for her sister right and I was like oh
wow that's like kind of mad that's
really weird and I was like you know I
had that happen I was like oh this
happened she was like you know my sister
got his number I was like wait your your
sister got his number she was like yeah
I was like how did she get his number so
oh well I gave her gave it to her I was
like wait I'm confused so did he go
after your sister or did your sister go
after him
because she was like he was like oh well
you know a pet she was like oh well he
said no because her sister said no
because you know he had already been
with her
and I was like wait but you gave your
sister her number his number right and
then did she reach out to him she was
like okay yeah so she reached out yeah
okay
it wasn't like he he called it off with
him then he went after your sister like
you ended things right she was
interested you gave her the number and
green lit the situation and then you
didn't like it after and I was a bit
like
after asking these questions I was like
she painted it kind of one way yeah when
I actually found out I was like yeah
yeah yeah it was completely yeah
more believable if she wasn't like the
fact that she got so mad because if
someone said something about you that's
like how did my teeth come into the
conversation
you might find it annoying right and so
you might be like okay like what up but
if you're getting like angry at
insulting people I'm just like well yeah
but you know from what she described
earlier I wouldn't be surprised if you
said if I'm a childhood of arguing my
brothers I'd have to lie every now and
again if I'm a child with arguments that
I feel like you know like I I like in
general I think once someone has that
defense that's so thick so thick there's
nothing you can like you can't actually
truly trust the story that comes out of
their mouth but is it being rude is that
it just sort of illustrate what Pearl's
been saying though about like not taking
that accountability yeah you know what I
mean like yeah yeah yeah yeah you called
her out on that too but it's not taking
accountability then there's lying yeah
like this is this like in this I'm
seeing a mixture of about three types of
things in one no but then it's like it
was pretty toxic
you don't get that you don't get that
toxic without getting trauma in a
relationship too
I'm sorry like you cannot it takes two
to tangle I won't yeah I will not deal
with this like
narrative that oh it's only him that's
toxic toxic [__] she just got toxic
right here but when you think when you
think about it you're supposed to listen
to your man right so like you're
supposed like you're not supposed to
argue with it hey Paul can I ask a
question as well didn't she say that
because I don't believe that as well
early one woman she was speaking about
her boyfriend uh about oh yeah it was
three years ago then we found out it's a
whole different X now I know I caught
that too yes how many exes were there
she was like she was like 22. yeah she
said oh 18 I was with him for you I was
like three years and then now you're 26.
it could be it could be a thing she was
like she could they could have broken up
when she was like well she said two and
a half she said she said it like in one
line she didn't mention she didn't say
oh that was that X by the way this other
X she literally just said oh yeah and
when I was 73 18. from your experience
what does that mean when women are like
Miss whatever the ACT oh like what is
that well when they miss their ex no no
when they're like the details of the
timelines they're off like what and
you're like in your experience what does
that typically mean well
but I'm asking like why okay so okay
it's very simple okay first okay for
here's a couple rubbed legs I picked up
number one she's a woman no I'm just
joking
[Laughter]
all right based
red flag number two that I picked up was
when I asked her are you a virgin she
was like
yes
and it's that phrase to do what she's
looking like this is the pause and then
number three okay you don't have to sit
there
and think and remember about the truth
you know the truth just comes up you're
like oh yeah it's just that that was
that right and so when she had to sit
back and like remember the truth I was
just like oh I don't know and then the
inconsistencies and the stories and then
kit with the with the KO punch was like
wait a minute because what we were
talking about after this and she was
like [__] you and your actor reward
[__]
I think when I met her she said my suit
was nice on the balcony didn't she like
she said something she said something
about my suit in the balcony she was
like yeah the suit was nice and then now
she's always coming into this I'm just
curious
in your experience like what are they
hiding like what is the some sort of
some sort of treachery and deception
that she because she women are smart
enough to know
how they're perceived yeah and they're
definitely under they're definitely know
when the camera's on them or they're
being interrogated by somebody and they
there's an authority over them so she's
like oh wait oh I'm definitely a virgin
yeah and uh did you notice how as well
though she said oh we shouldn't be
talking about this because I thought you
know your second point I thought that
the reason she paused was because she
didn't she felt uncomfortable with
revealing like talking about her
sexuality like that on a public forum
but then she then said oh yes I'm a
virgin but we should be talking about
this yeah yeah she was trying to get it
off yeah yeah that's what they'll do
they'll bring up a situation and when
you ask the questions they don't like
then they don't want to talk about it
but they always bring it up first always
but then that leads on to like what
we're talking about with how a lot of
men will leave their actions a lot of
females will leave with their emotions I
really think that what I saw earlier on
was a gigantic emotional response and a
defense mechanism along with a lot a lot
of emotions mixed in because because
well and the girl that came on that I
actually like believe was a virgin you
know like she was good
no she was great she was on um yeah yeah
you believe it right yeah was it the one
who wore glasses were a mask because she
didn't want to be upset yeah
so what was that no she was just really
she was really um I think she was on
fresh and fit once too uh yeah she was
on fresh and fit one she went super
viral on there no she was just a
sweetheart like she was just so sweet
um she wasn't defensive at all and she
wouldn't go around like I think she was
kind of like she didn't even want to say
that she was a virgin do you know what I
mean like she wanted to try to put it
out there like that and then what like
isn't that the ultimate Flex so like
yeah I am a virgin like why would you be
hesitant to release that information but
I mean all of us here we're obviously
we're all non-virgins right we're all
war no I just can't you're definitely
not virgin
she got mad when I said that I was like
are you a born-again virgin she's like
don't [__] tell that [__] to me yeah
I'm a proud born again
suit always comes into this though so
like
this
suit it's a nice suit I like it it's
Laurel Piana all of my suits are Laurel
piano you know think about it all bro
like when a woman's arguing with you
they'll try to get you where it hurts
didn't I say that earlier I said that
earlier in the relation she was like
when you're when you're logically making
a point she's like yeah well that's why
you have fake teeth and you're still
sucking [__] sucks
he loves it oh I hate your suit now oh
he's got nice teeth
it's just her being not I wouldn't want
to say it's her being a woman it's just
her being them like I don't want to say
family boy emotional emotional yeah yeah
she was I mean she was clearly triggered
clearly triggered and you don't get
triggered by
you know like lies and you you get
triggered by when somebody hits the
truth if she said that her body count
was full I wouldn't care no one else
would eat it no no I think I think I
think it's because and I'm not saying
this is what she was lying about but I
think it's because as a Muslim or
someone who writes yeah right Muslim and
this is a public forum right yeah yeah
there is a level of appearance and
reputation
certain age people just assume yeah yeah
it's 25 anyway you're expecting even if
she whatever religion you're what you're
expecting she's a virgin yeah and then
another and I wanted to tell her too
like for me personally like if a girl
has Snapchat that's a [__] red flag
that's just a red flag like what are you
doing for me personally like you're just
on a platform that deletes all evidence
it's like are you kidding me like and
then no like come on you're on and like
you're not even a social media is she an
influencer she have a big Channel she's
doing something she did she did say that
she is I'm youtubing and trying to get
back into it and like you know she's
she's saying she's starting up like you
know she's good she's got a platform as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this plot
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible